this weekend was really one of the most
uh consequential and busy weekends of
news for a long time we had the
continued russian invasion of ukraine
vladimir putin has coyly floated the
idea that maybe nukes are in the picture
by raising the readiness level of the
nuclear deterrent
systems we'll talk about that and
meanwhile republicans held their cpap
convention in orlando florida as if we
needed a reminder of the sick and
disgusting nature
of the right wing movement and in
addition to this there was a competing
convention afpak adjacent to cpac
geographically which was openly white
nationalist marjorie taylor green spoke
there mitt romney has called out more
quote [ __ ] republicans like marjorie
taylor green and so we have so much to
cover and let's get right into it
starting with russia
the first thing i want to just make sure
everybody understands is when number one
news is breaking so quickly on something
like ukraine russia
and number two
when some of the things that break as
news later turn out to have been
incorrectly reported so for example
videos that come out purporting to be
from ukraine and they're actually old
videos from russia that don't actually
mean what it seems they mean
we're trying to be careful and report
the things for which
we have good evidence to avoid confusing
anybody and to avoid
um uh creating more problems than than
just informing people
there is now
widespread confirmation
that vladimir putin has put nuclear
forces on high alert
now what that means is subject to some
debate and we're going to talk about
that but i'm going to make every effort
to give you all of the information we
know to be true but no more than that so
that people don't end up confused
the associated press reporting president
putin dramatically escalated east-west
tensions by ordering nuclear forces put
on high alert sunday while ukraine's
embattled leader agreed to talks with
moscow as putin's troops and tanks drove
deeper into the country closing in
around the capital citing aggressive
statements by nato and tough financial
sanctions putin issued a directive to
increase the readiness of russia's
nuclear weapons raising fears that the
invasion of ukraine could
could lead to nuclear war
whether by design or mistake the russian
leader is quote potentially putting in
play forces that if there's a
miscalculation could make things much
much more dangerous said a senior us
official
putin's directive came as russian forces
encountered strong resistance from
ukraine defenders moscow has so far
failed to win full control of ukraine's
airspace despite advances across the
country
another report from cbs news putin puts
nuclear forces on alert as fighting in
ukraine continues the way they
characterize it are the move means putin
has ordered russia's nuclear weapons
prepared
for increased readiness to launch
raising the threat that tensions could
boil over into a nuclear war
so
um oh and in the meantime by the way
belarus preparing to join russian
invasion of ukraine according to u.s
officials and of course we should always
have a healthy skepticism of what
intelligence agencies tell us on this
particular issue they have been mostly
right uh despite people saying oh we
can't believe this we can't trust this
it can't be trusted so that's the latest
belarus preparing to join so what are we
to make of this well first of all
consider the
contrast between first saying
the sanctions are toothless we don't
putin we don't care about the sanctions
the sanctions don't sanctions don't
affect us
next going to well we are potentially
going to attack u.s assets as a result
of the painful sanctions oh so the
sanctions you said don't affect you
actually are painful all the way up to
we are going to increase our state of
readiness when it comes to our nuclear
arsenal
uh as a result of those sanctions well
doesn't sound like the sanctions are
toothless if that's what you're willing
to do
um the other aspect of this that i think
is important
is like with everything else
we don't know what the point of this is
is the point to actually get ready to
launch nukes
it's hard for me to believe that because
the truth is the truth is
if you think you might quote need to
launch nukes or you think that you might
launch nukes for whatever reason
you're always sort of at a state of
readiness i mean this is kind of the
reality of how these nations work and
how these systems work so the
announcement that you're increasing the
state of readiness is less about
actually getting ready to launch nukes
you would always be ready to launch
nukes if that's what it came to and or
and to get to that state of readiness
readiness quickly it's more about
putting out there that this is it's
using the word nukes that's really the
big thing here and that's one
perspective that this is mostly meant to
be a psychological
escalation a rhetorical escalation
rather rather than a real one the
counterpoint to that is putin sort of
seems like the type of kid that you know
he poops in the sandbox when it's time
to go home because he doesn't want
anyone else to be able to play in it
either and that he genuinely
particularly if he is in the altered
state that some are describing might
consider using nukes the next question
is what exactly would he knew he wants
ukraine
it doesn't really make sense to nuke
ukraine if you want ukraine but he's not
rational
this is not a rational guy and so maybe
the point is use it as a rhetorical
deterrent
use it as something to say look i could
be crazy
don't keep escal don't don't keep
fighting back
because i'm i'm nuts and i'm liable to
use nukes we don't we don't know we
really just don't know and we also don't
know how the west would respond
if vladimir putin actually launched a
nuke it's easy to say well it would be a
suicidal action by putin oh yeah maybe
that it could be
but what exactly
what exactly is the response if if putin
launches a nuke at the same time
there are people who said i can't see
putin launching a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and we know those people were
wrong so this is what we know an
increased level of readiness has been
put forth
what it actually means we just don't yet
know
the next
major uh
piece of news coming out of russia
is the absolute and complete collapse of
russia's ruble which is the currency
r-u-b-l-e
now worth
less than one american cent
less than one american cent one of the
things that took place over the weekend
is that there have been swift bank
sanctions placed on russia now i don't
mean that they were swift and that they
were rapidly placed they weren't done
swiftly swift in all caps is an
inter-bank messaging system used to
transfer money internationally sometimes
when we have uh like an advertiser
that's based in a different country
swift codes are used to transfer money
back and forth and over the weekend it
was announced that indeed uh the there
are sanctions being placed on russia's
access to the swift system there was
every expectation that indeed the ruble
would collapse and it has collapsed
we're putting up the uh ruble dollar
exchange rate for you
and it looks like it fell off a cliff i
mean it looks like a mountain with a
seemingly vertical ledge and the value
of the ruble has completely and totally
collapsed now obviously the problem is
that this affects
innocent russian people
who oppose this invasion more than it
affects the oligarchs and putin the the
pressure on putin and oligarchs is going
to start to build it already is building
of course restricting air travel out of
russia restricting their assets in other
countries
shutting down swift collapsing the value
of their currency there's no question
about it but it's also really affecting
the russian people we can already see
this over the weekend there were bank
runs and atm runs all over russia we're
showing video to our video audience here
of people lined up in an atm to pull
money out and the money running out so
it's an unfortunate part of the point of
sanctions
part of the point of sanctions is turn
more people against putin
and turn even more people against him
when there are already people against
him to try to put pressure on him to
stop what he's doing now does putin care
about the suffering of the russian
people it's not clear it's not clear and
this happened in um
when there were sanctions
for germany for starting world war one
and it led to german people suffering
and later hitler used that to his
advantage
but i'm hearing from russians who oppose
the invasion
that they understand it's putin who's
doing this to russia
and they are suffering as a result of
what what is going on with the ruble so
then it's easy to say well go on the
street in protest many of them are and
then they get arrested so i think we
should not
ignore the reality that a lot of what is
happening is terrible for the russian
people also there are ukrainians getting
killed
so this isn't the sort of competition
about who is most
being uh
who who is most brutally suffering as a
result of this there's different types
of suffering and of course
most people would say i'd rather be poor
than die
meaning
have the ruble be worth nothing in
russia versus potentially get killed in
ukraine but obviously this is all much
more complicated than that now another
comment i received is communal pain
often will lead to communal action and
the idea that if the russian people now
all suffer together because of what's
going on with the ruble then
what then what is the question because
many of the protesters end up getting
arrested also not to be ignored is that
the ukrainian currency is suffering as
well we're putting now up on the screen
the the currency chart
of the ukrainian rivnia i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly also way down
not as much as the ruble on a percentage
basis so in addition to the bombing
happening in ukraine and the invasion
happening in ukraine ukrainian currency
also taking a major hit and uh we will
continue to see
whether these negotiations that are
reportedly starting between ukraine and
russia
lead anywhere over the next 24 hours
in the meantime there there are now
multiple reports which is why i'm ready
to bring it to you multiple reports that
russia has bombed
kindergartens and orphanages in ukraine
potentially committing war crimes
there's a report from ilya lazavsky a
writer and senior editor for the
organized crime and corruption reporting
project who tweeted
quote reports that a ukrainian
kindergarten used as a shelter was hit
i will not share the images as they are
too graphic absent and extremely
compelling explanation hard to imagine
what it could be
this is a war crime this was later
apparently corroborated by dimitro
culeba the minister of foreign affairs
of ukraine who tweeted quote today's
russian attacks on kindergartens and
orphanages are war crimes and violations
of the rome statute together with the
office of the attorney general we are
collecting these and other materials
which we will immediately transfer to
the hague
responsibility is inevitable now we
can't dismiss and the reason i keep
saying this is because this
it has happened already
we can't dismiss the possibility
that someone is mistaken here or that
this is somehow not as reported but
there are now
multiple reports and corroborations even
from ukrainian state officials that
there have been bombings of
kindergartens and orphanages and of
course
you know
all of the bombing is wrong that's going
on here the sovereignty of ukrainian
borders is being violated this is a this
is a
aggressive
action from putin all of those things
are true
in addition if indeed there are bombings
of kindergartens and orphanages taking
place then it makes it all the more
horrifying and it will likely take no
matter how how much longer this all goes
on and it could be two days it could be
two weeks it could be two months
probably not more than two months at
this at this level of escalation would
be my guess no matter how long it takes
much like with the trump administration
where it will take years to unwind
everything that happened
uh it will likely take
a long time
to find out everything that has taken
place over the last week in ukraine
let me know where your mind is on what
you expect to see over the next few days
here
find me on twitter at dpakman let me
know we'll take a quick break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right well i apologize to everybody
who has an allergy to high levels of
cringe but we do have to talk about cpac
over the weekend we are going to look at
some of the wackiest moments from cpac
we're going to look at um the various
speakers we'll look at the interviews
that donald trump gave before and after
his cpac speech but we're going to start
with donald trump's completely deranged
unhinged
yes febrile it's the last day of
february so it's the
i'll move on to a different adjective in
march but for february these are still
going to be described as febrile
speeches
donald trump uh at moments the crowd was
engaged at moments the crowd was
completely bored but
apparently announcing a 2024 run by all
estimations trump is saying he's running
in 2024. take a listen they're going to
find out the hard way starting on
november 8th
and then again even more so on
november 2024
they will find out like never before
we did it twice
and we'll do it again we're going to be
doing it again
so this
seems as though it is donald trump
announcing that he is running for
president in 2024 all right are we i
know it's not a formal announcement and
a formal announcement would bring with
it different sorts of limitations and
financial requirements and reporting and
things with trump wants to avoid but it
seems that he's saying he's going to run
um trump kind of bringing out all the
hits that we became used to during his
presidency one is those sort of weird
some people call them like neurological
glitches it's where trump messes up a
word and and sort of twitches and it's
weird let's take a look at one of those
there were a handful system to persecute
you you it is a persecution and and
again we don't know what that is it
comes there's a there's a twitch
and he messes up a word and then tries
to get back on track we we we just don't
know what this is we'll look and you
really have to see it let's look at it
once more system to persecute you you is
a person yeah we don't know we we just
we don't know what that is um another
classic from trump is uh the sir
routines stories where trump uses the
word sir are almost always stories that
didn't happen sir sure yeah so here's
trump telling one of his sir stories
i've had great people come up to me and
tell me sir ma'am please ask you a
question
yes what would you like to know sir
how did you take it how did you take it
multiple sirs there and that story
almost certainly didn't happen trump
shouting out his former doctor who's now
a congressman a congressman
uh and talking about how the doctor got
to know every inch of trump
a man that knows me almost better than
any human being
he knows every inch of me
and he thinks it's actually a very
beautiful sight so just
very weird i mean i i can't say that
that's not funny but it's just all
pretty weird donald trump then seemingly
tries to take credit for getting the
united states out of iraq and out of
afghanistan neither of which happened
while trump was president i mean i don't
know that it matters to him but those
things didn't happen while he was
president remember though
when so many people in the democrat
party and during the debates
said he's going to get us into the third
world war with trump i'm the one that
didn't have any wars i'm the one
that got us out of wars look at iraq
look at syria i was the one that brought
us way down
in afghanistan i brought you down to
2000 soldiers the easy part was just
getting out i brought it down from 20
000 soldiers to 2 000 soldiers the easy
part was for biden to just get him out
let the soldiers stay the remaining
soldiers and take care of everything
it's called
soldiers outlast i went to a child yeah
so very very confusing thing he says he
got us out of iraq which he didn't he
did draw down troops in afghanistan but
then he says he left biden the easy part
but then biden should have let him stay
but it was easy to take him out it's all
very very confused it doesn't actually
make any sense trump then again telling
one of these stories of where he refers
to a taliban leader as abdul now for a
while when he said when he would refer
to this leader he would refer to him as
muhammad so it's not clear trump knows
the guy's name or maybe he's using abdul
slash muhammad as a placeholder for it
was a muslim guy it's not really clear
and he tells a story again it probably
never happened that he showed a story a
picture of the guy's house as a threat
to the leader it's very very weird
but i said abdul you're killing
ourselves jesus you better i cannot kill
ourselves
because if you do you will be hit
like no country has ever been hit you
will be hit harder than anybody has ever
been
and he said mr president but why
he actually called me your excellency i
don't know do you think he calls
biden your excellency buddy
he goes but why your excellency mr
president
do you send me a picture of my house
[Applause]
and i said i'd rather not answer that
question that almost certainly
never ever ever
trump then tells the lie that again
hillary spied on my campaign of course
the crowd demands hillary be locked up
now we know that crooked hillary
not only spied on my campaign she spied
on the white house
remember none of that is true that's not
what the durham report filing said it's
there's no evidence that that's true but
the crowd doesn't care
so the crowd chanting lock her up and of
course remember hillary clint these are
the people of law and order and due
process hillary clinton has not even
been charged never mind convicted of any
crimes locking such a person up is weird
then a really unusual contrast happened
during his riffing part because trump
does this thing during these speeches
where he'll read a little bit of
something off the prompter and then
he'll riff and in his riff he criticized
the supreme court which is one third
made up of people he selected and then
later off the prompter he
bragged about how he chose conservatives
to the court it's very funny because he
doesn't even know that this is a direct
contrast so here he is trying to go to
the audience and to booing the supreme
court justice
justices
but even our supreme court justices and
it's sad to say this right are afraid to
do what has to be done to save our
country
they're trying so desperately to be
politically correct
and to be loved by all these are the
justices of the united states supreme
court so trump there criticizing the
supreme court and what he means guys is
they didn't flip the election to him
that's really what he means but funny
later off the prompter he brags about
how he selected conservatives to the
court wait but these are the
conservatives you just attacked
ship as your president i kept my promise
and chose supreme court justices
on the list i gave to the country before
the 2016 election i gave a list of great
brilliant conservative justices
so they're now taking credit for the
great conservative justices and then
lastly and this is the funniest moment
trump starts reading his closing and
because trump struggles to read off of
the teleprompter he pauses at a weird
moment where it sounds like he's saying
i'm here today as your president trump
was actually about to read a list of
things he did as president but the crowd
is so weaponized when trump says as your
president
they think he's saying i am now your
president and they go crazy cheering and
with a standing ovation it's beyond
parody this is a sick cult in summation
and in closing as your president
i instituted
oh god
you understand what's happening right
the crowd thinks trump is saying in
summation as your president right he's
saying i'm here today as your president
and the crowd cheers remember if it's
trump alone doing these things and
nobody cares and nobody pays attention
it's one crazy guy
when you have a roomful a movement full
of people who love this stuff it's just
a reminder and that's what cpac was of
how sick
and dangerous and delusional this entire
movement is in the united states that's
trump's speech to cpac let's now look at
a little bit of the sort of little press
conference that donald trump gave so
before giving his
completely deranged cpac speech donald
trump actually took some questions and
there were actually some interesting
questions asked and trump was visibly uh
sweaty disheveled he seemed confused by
many of the questions but some of the
questions were actually pretty
interesting and this one it's this this
this one would almost make you blush if
trump answered it any other way
trump was asked as many of you may have
heard the president of ukraine
has stayed in ukraine and is fighting
he's fighting in ukraine trying to repel
the russian invasion and trump was asked
if you were in such a situation would
you also stay and fight
and it's like of course he wouldn't of
course we would trump would be the first
guy out he'd say please evacuate me and
trump knows he can't say i would be
fighting because no one would believe it
so even he has to kind of hedge it's
pretty interesting take a look at this
and you know he's not abandoning his
people he's staying and taking up arms
with his countrymen if you were in a
similar situation as president would you
take up arms like zolensky
well you know you never know about
bravery some people think they're brave
and they're not brave and other people
don't think of themselves as very brave
and they step up you never know until
you get tested
[Laughter]
even for trump it would be too much to
say i would be out there with with a
rifle absolutely uh and so he
it's actually he he has this moment
where he knows he can't say that nobody
would believe that um i think we know
the answer trump would not be taking up
arms like zelensky trump would be either
in the bunker or in another country
altogether and uh it listen it's more
likely trump would give away classified
documents if he was in silence position
then he would stay and take up arms and
fight anybody trump was then asked and
this was pretty interesting
what would you do differently on ukraine
than biden because trump saying biden's
doing everything wrong and trump says i
guess for security reasons he doesn't
want to tell you what he would do
differently i'll tell you what i would
do things but the last thing i want to
do is say it right now because
if somebody asks me that is in a
position where they can
utilize whatever it is i give them but i
i certainly wouldn't want to be talking
about right no he it's just not
appropriate and of course he has no idea
of what he would do differently he's
just he says it's biden's fault but
this is sort of like he's prepared to
release his health care plan soon and
he's going to give us the vote evidence
of voter fraud soon it's all just around
the corner also his infrastructure plan
um then one oh now later in the
interview and this is kind of in a
different moment trump is asked about
what what about he he actually does
answer what he one thing he would do and
he says he would um
get russia uh out of swift the swift
banking system
which happened hours before this trump
apparently just didn't know that very
very important question to be asked
what is the one sanction or the two
sanctions that have not been implemented
to stop vladimir putin that you would
implement given a trump presidency
sanctions now you have to understand
sanctions are very expensive for our
country also
but the one that people are talking
about which is very very severe as you
know is swift and that just really
destroys a banking system of a country
it's a very big step
and we'll see whether or not that step
is taken but
thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people could die with this
and this could spread to other
countries and it could spread throughout
the world i mean this could be a world
war yes okay so so now trump
changing his tune and saying this
actually could become a world war but at
the time that he said the one thing that
that you could look at doing is swift it
had been done that it happened hours
before trump apparently didn't know so
those are the trump interviews that's
the trump speech it was wacky we'll have
some of these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
and then after the break we'll look at
the non-trump craziness that happened at
cpac
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
david
patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show there are some republicans very few
who i still disagree with politically
but they have the recognition
and apparently the common sense to see
what the conservative right-wing
republican movement has been taken over
by in the united states
and to say these people are morons one
such person who literally used that word
is mitt romney and we're going to talk
about that a little bit later but first
we're going to take a tour through cpac
cpac the conservative political action
conference was in orlando florida over
the weekend and we already looked at
donald trump's speech which was
outrageous completely outrageous and
corrosive to democracy in every way
but i want to now just show you that
it was not an anomaly or an anomaly
whatever your preference is on the
pronunciation both are correct despite
me being criticized no matter which of
the two i use uh no but in all
seriousness um
it was it was just all completely
bonkers
um here is radical republican
congresswoman lauren bober saying she
has already filed articles of
impeachment against biden kamala harris
and nancy pelosi
is that even true and if so like what
are they for she doesn't say solution
that i have put forward
the paperwork's already been filed she's
filed it already we haven't heard i
guess but she's filed it i have
introduced articles of impeachment to
impeach joe biden and peach kamala
harris get nancy pelosi the heck out of
there and save our country god bless you
all i'll see you next year this is a
perfect example of i'm going to say
something loudly
and people will clap
and the words could be anything right i
mean she could have just said i have
just filed for sending the first humans
to jupiter's great eye and people go
yeah
okay i mean it's
whatever it's just it's just the the
tone and speaking of tone
this is bizarre
remember larry kudlow trump's economic
advisor
he couldn't possibly be lower energy he
went up on stage he speak speaking like
someone a minute before coming on stage
just told him someone had died close to
him or something lit this is
i guess this is supposed to inspire
people look at this
subpoena free and i got a new job
with fox business
so i hope you watch our show it's called
kudlow
please watch the show please
watch this
my show's pretty good here's the thing
we have adopted a mantra i have adopted
a mantra
for
the show yeah but for everything
and it's called save america
right that is what i want to talk to you
about today save america
okay uh the i don't i don't know who
appears more comatose uh the
the audience or larry kudlow really a
bundle of energy as you can see uh then
uh you may have heard that papa john
this is john schnatter he's the guy from
the papa john's pizza company
who was very much against obamacare he
said you know if if i have to give
everybody health care uh it's gonna sort
of cost me like 10 cents a pizza and he
was very very strongly against it a
conservative thought leader you might be
able to say
he suggests biden goaded putin into
invading ukraine in order to distract
from the so-called real issues which is
quite a quite a big brain conspiracy
theory
here we go administration vitamin c
totally incompetent or they do this
intentionally when you cut off our
pipeline and you open up brushes and you
give the guys 750 billion dollars looks
to me like it's pretty intentional but
what a great smokescreen what a great
distraction from all the real issues
here that are affecting americans so
um i think it's home screen i think it
was intentional yeah it was intentional
to create a smoke screen says
conservative thought leader papa john
about uh what's happening geopolitically
and foreign relations exactly uh then
and this is where if you thought this
was crazy then it gets really crazy the
missouri state attorney general eric
schmidt says the constitution would soon
be replaced by the communist manifesto
if democrats got their way
they want to replace the declaration of
independence with a communist manifesto
right that's obviously untrue there are
essentially no communists in power in
the united states there are certainly
some social democrats i guess there's a
couple democratic socialists although
even they seem confused as to whether
they're really democratic socialists
people like bernie and aoc i don't know
that they're even really democratic
socialists so why would the communist
manifesto be put anywhere doesn't make
sense cpac speaker charles herbster
who's a candidate for governor in
nebraska
this is unbelievable he
the republicans over the weekend
realized pushing pushing putin is bad we
got to be pro ukraine they don't really
care one way or the other they just want
to do what sells
and so now they've started saying
ukraine is the good guy and so charles
herbster asks the crowd to kneel and say
a prayer for ukraine and the camera cuts
to the audience and nobody's nobody
cares certainly nobody's kneeling but
it's it's wild they they just don't care
i'm gonna ask all of you to do a favor
even if it's a little uncomfortable yeah
you with your spouse is here
kneel down
and give a prayer
for what's taking place in ukraine right
first of all so far it's not clear
whether he wants them to pray for the
invasion to continue or for it to stop
it's sort of unclear from this so far
but let's keep going
they we they need our prayers
yeah that zelinski character
he's a hero right uh
mild very muted applause and certainly
nobody praying a couple of the panels
that they had
one of them is lock her up for real
referring of course to hillary clinton
this is beyond parody
ladies and gentlemen it's time for
locker up for real
oh my god and then here's another very
very hard-hitting panel
ladies and gentlemen this is fire fouchy
a series of curated speeches
here very very carefully curated yeah
and then lastly here's todd stearns who
just openly anti-vaxx and this is not
against mandates this is just anti-vaxx
and you tell dr fauci to stick those
vaccines where the sun don't shine
god bless you all god bless america and
let's fight bouchy yep so um
these are very sick people but i want to
remind you and here's my my kind of last
thought on cpac
um they are so good at this the left
doesn't have this type of unity they
don't have the willingness to pour money
into events like this and to get
everybody together to get everybody on
message the messages are idiotic fire
fouchy lock up hillary who hasn't been
charged with any crime
uh all the messages could not be more
absurd and destructive
but they are so good at organizing in
this way and the left is not now one of
the side stories at cpac is that my
pillow ceo mike lindell
had a complete and total meltdown in the
exhibit hall uh robert costa is a
reporter for cbs news and there's video
of pillow
flipping out and calling robert costa a
traitor
there were times when if a business
leader behaved this way their business
would be shut down within a month
because everybody would say i'm not
going to buy from this guy but look at
the behavior of pillow check this out
he's a traitor to the united states
[Music]
okay so we actually have a better angle
and audio so this is from robert costa
actually filming it himself and pillows
completely irrational he seems totally
out of his mind and trump actually
during his speech
said mike pillow's here he's so great
and the crowd gave him a standing
ovation this is how the guy was behaving
in the hallway
[Applause]
traders trainers cbs robert koska is a
traitor to united by the way costco i
love them states of america no you're a
trader this is all news you're
regurgitating you care about why you
protect a company called dominion and
you attack a company call my pillow
you're a traitor to our country you're a
disgusting leader trader trader trader
trainer trainer trader trainer
what's funny is costa's really a pretty
uncontroversial reporter he's just he's
just a reporter yes you're one step
above fox who doesn't talk at all that's
what you guys are he's asking me about
the picture at the white house a year
ago you're disgusting by the way the
picture at the white house a year ago
where pillow came out and the zoom in
showed that it said like state of
emergency on his piece of paper martial
law something like that that's that we
still haven't really gotten answers to
that and i asked pillow about it during
our interview and he was he was pretty
evasive it's hard to find a more
deranged guy more in over his head than
mike pillow and trump actually praised
him and uh here's just one more clip
this is phoenix kid reporter asking
pillow for an example of the election
fraud and um pillow didn't like it and
walked away
here we go
so what did you think of president
trump's speech one of his best friends
ever
and why do you think that is well
because he brought up all the election
crimes
the 2020 election crimes all the stuff
that's happening we got to keep getting
the word out and he told the media how
rotten they are that they never reported
anything that's that's going to help
save our country what election crimes
i'm not
are you serious
really no i'm saying for people who
haven't really heard no they all know
tell them to go to frankenspeech.com
lindell tv you can see all the crime
right there
and then he walks away uh phoenix kid
reporter instantly triggering uh mike
pillow there so
it's out of control after the break
we'll talk about the event next door
afpak the openly white nationalist
competitor to cpac
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so let's talk about what's going on with
republican senator mitt romney um you
know i i think when it comes to people
like romney we have to be able to call
things what they are and say
compared to
this modern trumpian cult that includes
people like trump
trump's family marjorie taylor greene
lauren bober these types compared to
them
mitt romney seems and feels so
comparatively benign
at the same time he's still a guy that i
disagree with politically on a number of
different issues mitt romney and i have
different economic views views on
taxation views on social welfare
programs views on foreign policy and
of course of course
but
compared to the completely delusional
weaponized nature of the modern american
trumpian right
he's not nearly as bad
and
that doesn't mean we're glorifying mitt
romney it just says we're talking about
things on a spectrum
he has at least taken like a minor moral
stand against the most insane aspects of
the republican party he's anti-trump etc
and
he also
mostly voted with the things that trump
wanted right like roughly 80 of the time
it's not 95 percent of the time but it's
still 80 of the time and over the
weekend
mitt romney
sort of provided some moral clarity on
uh cnn about russia ukraine saying it's
very clear which side we should be on
here let's take a listen to mitt romney
would be done by the u.n or by us but
clearly the humanitarian
demand may may be such that that we will
look for a way to allow the mothers and
children that are currently being
huddled in subway stations to be able to
find refuge right and look at the people
of poland how heroic they are providing
the clothing and the and the housing and
the food for these refugees that are
they're pouring into their country and
also in romania look look this is this
is one of the
the greatest demonstrations of good
versus evil that we've seen during our
lifetimes and and the demonstration of
courage i mean look look at vladimir
putin vladimir putin here he is in this
this uh
behind this huge table in this big white
room i mean it looks like a mausoleum
where where uh honesty and honor have
gone to die and contrast that with
zelensky with his courage with his
passion which with his true leadership
this is remarkable and it's having an
impact and and i hope it makes us a
better people and it makes us more
committed to the principles of freedom
so this is the perfect example of
differences of opinion with someone
who at least on this issue has his head
modestly on straight
versus insanity like biden stole the
election hillary should be imprisoned
the vaccines are killing people all of
that sort of stuff
romney says
biden
has done some really good things putting
pressure on russia and he also could
have done more
that's a reasonable position i want to
go back in time a little bit senator do
you think it was a mistake for president
biden to rule out
u.s troops on the ground instead of
trying to use what's known as strategic
ambiguity to deter vladimir putin from
invading in the first place
well there really wouldn't have been an
ambiguity we don't have the kind of
troop strength uh and and material of
war in the region to be uh to be a
serious threat at at that point uh look
the the uh
the bite administration has done some
things very well and some things not so
well the not so well side as they
continued the policy of prior
administrations not to provide the
defensive weapons ukraine needed
that was the mistake the positive thing
was
sharing our intelligence with our allies
and combining
our efforts with our allies look we used
to be 40 of the world economy today
we're about half of that and and so for
us to have the kind of economic clout we
used to have back in the 50s and 60s and
70s we really do need to combine with
our allies and this is it's
it's crazy that like i i i don't love
romney and i disagree with him on so
much stuff but he's at least willing to
say
biden did some things that were fine and
here's things i would have done
differently whereas you have so many of
these trumpian republicans now who
anything biden does anything biden does
is by definition bad now then he got
into the just absolute hammer fist drops
on on people like marjorie taylor green
and goes-r he was asked about them and
he just called the morons uh and said
that
they're they're sort of like low iq
people listen to this this is wild
you talked several times during this
interview about the world seeing the
difference between good and evil i want
to bring that closer to home and talk
about something that congresswoman liz
chaney tweeted
yesterday about sitting republican house
members appearing at a white nationalist
gathering she said quote as
representative marjorie taylor greene
and paul gosar speak at this white
supremacist anti-semitic pro-putin event
silenced by republican party leaders is
deafening and enabling all americans
should renounce this garbage and reject
the putin wing of the gop now
do you agree
absolutely liz cheney was right with
that statement and she's been right for
a long time and i also saw
that uh the ronald mcdaniel came out
with a statement as well uh uh
talking about how repugnant these white
nationalists are look there's no place
in and either political party uh for
this white nationalism or racism it's
simply wrong
now unfortunately a place has been made
in romney's party for it like i guess
he's saying there shouldn't be a place
but there's been a place in it for years
now
it's it's uh as as you've indicated
speaking of evil it's evil as well and
uh and you know marjorie taylor green
and paul gosar i don't know them but i'm
reminded of that old line from the butch
cassidy the sundance kid movie where
where one character says morons i've got
morons on my team and i have to think
anybody that would sit down with white
nationalists and speak at their
conference was certainly missing a few i
keep iq points
wow
wow uh i mean listen he's right he's
right and you can disagree obviously
with someone's politics or beliefs but
appreciate some of the things that they
say or do and it sort of tells you
everything you need to know about the
republican party that
most of mitt romney's utterances today
sounds sensible
he's still a right winger in the end but
it's such a contrast to the absurdity i
mean remember his gaffe i've got binders
full of women which at the time was a
gaff
it's almost quaint now and i'm not
dismissing the fact that it was sort of
inherently kind of you know the concept
of having binders of women it's all
you could argue it sounds misogynistic
and i'm not denying any of that but
compared to what's going on now even
that is a gaffe starts to seem almost
quaint so i'm not saying i want to vote
for romney or anything like that but the
contrast is incredible and he's right
they have morons in their wings and
unfortunately
romney is the exception at this point in
time unfortunately marjorie taylor green
seems to be more the way that the party
is going and we're going to talk about
that next so there was this competing
conference to cpac over the weekend
called afpak the america first
yeah the america first political action
conference
it is a white nationalist far-right
conference
overtly so you could say well isn't cpac
sort of that cpac is
what's crazy is cpac is now a
radicalized version of what republicans
used to be
afpak is a radicalized cpac and uh there
were a whole bunch of different white
nationalist extremists at the rally
and her conference and marjorie taylor
green
was a headline speaker at the event and
she was then rightly criticizing you
went to what is almost an out and out
nazi event it's a white nationalist
event these are some of the absolute
worst people right now and she claims
ignorance to all of it so let's take a
look she said i was there because i want
to speak to young people let's listen
but i'm glad to talk to you about this i
do not know nick fuentes i've never
heard him speak i've never seen a video
i don't know what his views are so i'm
not blind with anything that may be
controversial what i can tell you is i
went to his event last night to address
his very large following because that is
a young it's a very young following and
it's a generation i'm extremely
concerned about it's a white noise
excuse me i'll tell you exactly why i
went i went to talk to them about
american first policies and i talked to
them about what it's interesting she
says she doesn't know who nick fuentes
is and she doesn't know anything about
the white nationalist leanings of he and
the group
but she knows that these are young
people and that there's a bunch of them
and that they care about america first
and for for having no idea who these
people were
you seem to know a lot about it i spoke
here knowing it was a large group of
young people engaged in america first
policy controversies white nationalism i
don't know anything about that so i just
wanted to speak to them to give them my
america first ideas absurd she then put
out a written statement uh where she
said i mean look at look at this
self-victimization the pharisees in the
republican party may attack me
for being willing to break barriers what
what a martyr huh and speak to a lost
generation of young people who are
desperate for love and leadership but i
won't abandon these young men and women
because i believe we need to do better
by them i won't cancel others if the
conservative in the conservative
movement even if i find some of their
statements tasteless marge
it's a white nationalist event
i encourage them to seek wisdom and
apologize to those who have been hurt by
their words or as i've had to do our
faith calls for charity and forgiveness
and then she just goes completely insane
i'll keep fighting against identity
politics and marxism
what marxism are you fighting against
i'll keep speaking out and speaking up
our nation is only capable of protecting
sovereignty and then um
uh pulling out this insane statement the
atheist media demands no disavow from
left-wing politicians who hang out with
jihadist and abortionists but they
demand immediate disavowals of any
republican willing to speak to twelve
hundred people gathered to declare that
christ is king
and brand them in headlines exclusively
by their sins uh just as a little
sampling of what there was at this
afpack event
just before bringing on marjorie taylor
greene
there was uh nick fuentes saying that
their secret sauce is young white men
and then everybody started chanting
putin putin
and you want to know the secret
to borrow a phrase from a friend of mine
our secret sauce here it's these young
white men
that's what we call a secret ingredient
america and the world has forgotten
about them but not us
i don't think anybody's forgotten about
young white men say about
america they say
diversity is our strength you know and i
look at china and i look at russia
can we give a round of applause for
russia
yes
absolutely absolutely yeah so then
marjorie taylor green spoke and uh the
rest is sort of history these are really
dangerous movements and there's levels
right there's concentric circles it's
like okay you've got the entire right
wing like all right well that's a pretty
big range you've got absolute lunatic
murderous extremists and you've got
people where
i disagree with them about what the top
tax rate should be okay all right but
then you've got to find within that
you've got
the trumps the trumpians
and then you've got the cpac trumpians
and then you've got people like marjory
taylor green
and then you've got so there's these
concentric circles and unfortunately it
can all spread outward and infect the
entire movement and that's how you end
up with more than half believing joe
biden didn't really win the 2020
election
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here's a caller asking why isn't my show
about video games
hey i'm a big fan of the show uh when i
heard that there was a david pakman
doing a podcast i was hoping that you
would be talking about miss pac-man
patterns or pac-man patterns right our
miss pac-man strategies i can't imagine
having the name pac-man and not you know
mentioning the basic part of your
identity sure maybe um you know i love
your show and what you're doing with it
but maybe talk about pac-man a little
bit i don't know
all right thank you yeah no that's
certainly an idea the entire show could
be about the video game pac-man you know
growing up it's actually good that now
the there's a generational change where
people aren't aware of this as much
when i was between 10 and 18
anytime anybody would see my last name
it was oh did your dad invent the video
game it's like and i started saying yes
um but it sort of started to fade away a
little bit now
because i guess i mean i guess the
game's just not that popular or
something
but uh i guess worst comes to worst i
can always turn this show into a video
game show if news and politics doesn't
work it's good to know it's a
possibility we have such a packed bonus
show for you today
there are russians protesting the
invasion of ukraine and they're
protesting it in russia
and hundreds have gotten arrested
hundreds of people arrested just for
protesting in russia
fifa is not yet ready to ban russia from
the upcoming world cup in qatar
but
they have decided that the russian team
will not be allowed to use the russian
flag
and they will not be allowed to play the
russian national anthem
as punishment for the russian invasion
of ukraine does this make sense or does
it not make sense we're going to talk
about that and
rt television
russian state media around the world
they exist in canada the u.s etc uh rt
has been demonetized in the united
states
rt is getting removed from a canadian
cable system
our friend farron cousins and mike pap
antonio have pulled their show from rt
uh what is next for rt we're going to
talk about that on today's bonus show as
well i would love for you to become a
member at joinpacman.com
we are experiencing a bunch of people
they're kind of like in the tulsi
alt left
glenn greenwald wing of the of the left
if you believe that those people are on
the left
they're coming after us hard
and the they've been cancelling
membership some of them actually used to
support our show and because i've said
this alt left stuff is bad it's really
really bad they've started to cancel
memberships and they're trying to hurt
us financially and that's okay i don't
want their i don't want their money i
don't
but i would love it if you came in and
said david i actually appreciate what
you're doing on on the ukraine russia
issue uh sign up at jointpakman.com it's
really cheap and you'll also get access
to an extra show every day called the
bonus show alex jones hates the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad yeah
you'll also get the daily show
commercial free
six hours before everybody else so sign
up at joinpacman.com
we'll see you on the bonus show tomorrow
we'll have a new show a new bonus show
and i will be live for joe biden's state
of the union so a big week ahead